so when you start thinking about the
fiat system
most people think of it as two
completely diametrically opposed
systems right one is transparent
decentralized open source
uh programmatic et cetera and the other
is
basically the exact opposite is that
your general read on the two systems or
do you have some sort of
uh kind of more nuance to the comparison
um there's there's a lot to the
comparison so i think the
perhaps the most uh powerful tool is
when you try and think about how mining
works in fiat
so in bitcoin we know that you know the
miners solve the proof of work problems
and then they get issued new coins and
there's a schedule for how many coins
they get
in gold we know that you mine gold by
digging into the ground and then
refining it
but in fiat if you ask yourself how is
fiat mined
it's a very deep rabbit hole and when
you start thinking about it and start
thinking about the significance
in terms of you know just think about
how much of a big deal mining bitcoin is
and then you transport you
you apply that to fiat and you can see
why
uh lending is such a big deal because
the way that
mining fiat works is through lending
when you go to the bank
and you ask them for a million dollars
so you can buy a house the bank
isn't taking one million dollars that
somebody else had deposited in that bank
and giving them to you
the bank is making mining essentially
new fiat so
if they can get you to borrow they get
to make new fiat money
that's the equivalent of solving a proof
of work problem it's finding a lender
finding a borrower
who wants to borrow and who fulfills the
criteria for borrowing
and then being able to issue the loan
that allows them to make more money
when you think about it this way the
fiat system begins to make a lot of
sense so
that's why everybody's in debt that's
why
in fiat you know no matter how much
money you get you just keep
rolling it over into bigger and bigger
debt people don't make money so they can
pay off their debts people make money so
they can take on
bigger debts so individuals are in debt
corporations are in debt
governments are in debt at all levels
municipal and national and everything
everybody needs to get in debt
because when you get in debt you know if
you wanted to buy the house uh
with cash if you just had a house and
you wanted to buy it with cash well
that's to say a million dollar house
but if you're able to get it with a
mortgage
then the bank is going to effectively
make eight hundred thousand dollars out
of thin air
you'll put up say twenty thousand two
hundred thousand uh up front
but then the bank managed to make eight
hundred thousand so they can cut you a
sweet deal here because
it's not like you're uh taking up uh
you know it's not like you're taking up
their capital they just get to make new
capital so
if buying a house can be used as a way
to mine
fiat it's going to be very profitable
for the miner and they'll cut you in
on that and that's why it makes sense
for everybody to buy their houses
in that everybody buys uh their houses
and their
major expenses you get into debt and you
get a better deal than if you pay cash
because obviously you know over time the
value of the money declines
and the value of the repayment of the
loan continues to decline
so when you think about uh let's talk
nation state debt versus
individual debt and corporate debt there
there's different
players in the market that are all
taking on debt is it fair to say it's
all the exact same
structure so the government takes on
debt because they're going to be able to
pay it off with cheaper dollars in the
future
same as the individual buying that house
or some other good um
is that kind of a fair way to categorize
in your opinion
um i mean it's not exactly the same
because uh depends on your credit
worthiness and it depends on your
political connections and so the issue
here of course is that
this isn't uh this isn't an advanced and
fair system like bitcoin where
anybody can solve the proof of work
problems and get rewarded
and the only way to guarantee that you
can make more solutions for the proof of
work
is to mine more efficiently and
have more miners and have more
electricity well in fiat it doesn't
quite work that way in order to mine
fiat
basically you need to be well connected
to the federal reserve to the government
to the central bank in whatever country
you're in and the way it works is
government obviously gets to borrow at
the lowest rate because government has
the advantage of being able to
um tax and inflate the currency
to pay off the debt so therefore you'll
see that they get to borrow at the
lowest rate everywhere
and then everybody else's um interest
rate will be a little bit higher so
effectively
you know you people are mostly probably
familiar with the term the cantion
effect and the canteen effect refers to
the fact that when you
print new money the recipients of the
new money
benefit at the expense of the people who
were holding the old money
and the people who receive it earlier
benefit the most
and then as the money trickles through
the rest of the economy
the benefits decline and then the people
who receive it later
don't even benefit from it they are hurt
from the inflation that it causes
so in the case of fiat the way the
canteeon effect is essentially
the way that the cathedral effect works
is essentially through
interest rate um people who get lowest
interest rates
on their debt benefit and so that's
government
and the biggest borrowers in society
which are
primarily the biggest the biggest
financial institutions in banks
and then the bigger corporations that
can borrow from
uh the banks at the lowest interest
rates but then as you move forward as
you move towards you know the
uh hoi polloi and the peasants the
interest rates go up
and you are effectively uh missing out
on the benefits of this you're not being
able to catch up with inflation
if you think about inflation in terms of
cpi
then you could get the impression that a
lot of people are able to keep up with
inflation but of course
that's entirely dependent on the kind of
goods that you include in the cpi and
that does not include
the desirable goods that are highly
competitive because they're rare you
know you can't have
miami beach real estate and
manhattan real estate in the cpi because
that's
always going up much faster than cpi and
the best healthcare the best medicine
the best all the things that are very
scarce by their nature because they're
very high quality
all these things are rising at a much
faster pace than the cpi
and so the only people who can keep up
are the ones who are the
best connected so essentially government
and the big banks and
the people who are you know the people
who run these things
you